what I'm talking about is something that
will take a generation to do and I need
to start there is that if we're looking
for a healthcare fix for something as
complex with with the the previous
choices we've made in healthcare that's
going to have a fundamental impact on
our system it's hopeless to too many of
us depend on the current forms of
financing I have spent our lives
participating in it for an instantaneous
change and frankly the whole healthcare
industry which is almost a fifth of our
economy has been set up with an existing
system so the first thing you need is a
generation commitment it's taken roughly
50 years to create this mess you're not
going to solve it in 12 you're really
going to have to be committed to
fundamental change over time that's a
very hard thing for our or frankly any
political system to do other than
accidentally we did it accidentally with
Medicare and Medicaid and and company
funded insurance to do it intentionally
as much harder but that's number one
it's just a realistic sense of what it's
going to take beyond that I think there
are really three important elements
number one I believe and I think many
Americans do that there really does need
to be a true cradle to grave safety net
for all Americans for catastrophic
health which is really the initial
starting point of many of these debates
in some cases over a hundred years ago
in the developed world we still don't
have that and I think I think at two
hundred will be up to near to and I have
trillion dollars of spending next year
the number one question we need to ask
ourselves as how on earth do we spend
two and i have trillion dollars on
health care a year and i'll have a true
safety net for health catastrophes for
all Americans that's number one and to
me what that's about is catastrophic
insurance it actually is an insurable
good unlike so much of what isn't in
shirt in healthcare and I start there
and it needs to be a national pool
because we can't get into the situation
we see now when we have private
insurance insurers competing for profit
growth in part on how successful they
are on underwriting out the worst cases
we can't just let the public pay for the
worst cases it's actually an
extraordinarily if latian area approach
to creating an insurance boat we need a
national poll beyond that though we have
to look at
non-catastrophic air which does include
late life care because it's planibel
right unlike most insurance events it's
something that we can plan during our
life and that we do fun during our life
but also a lot of disease management
issues and frankly a lot of routine care
in the ways we fund other things in our
economy how do we do that we do that out
of income out of savings out of credit
against future savings and so what I
would like to see over time is a shift
in the enormous resources that we
currently pay to support the insurance
system back to consumers to allow them
both to fund their current medical
expenses and to save for future ones if
it has a couple of benefits benefit
number one is it returns us to our role
as consumers it does something we have
to start with one I think now
indisputable fact which is our 50-year
reliance on employers on insurer's on
governments to control costs have failed
all right we will hear endless details
of how we can do it better and this or
this new regulation will finally do it
but if you follow the last 50 years of
healthcare we've tried a lot of
different things at Medicare and
Medicaid and private insurance and that
theory that big will exercise leverage
and leverage will keep prices down you
know if T years of the past experience
hasn't taught us that doesn't work that
I guess we'll need more years but I at
least I think many others believe at
some point you say okay this doesn't
work what will well the one thing we
really haven't tried is to do what works
everywhere else which is to have a mass
of disaggregated thinking consumers
pushing prices force and quality forcing
accountability that's number one I i do
want to come back to criticisms that
approach because there's some important
criticisms of that approach but that is
you know where I start the second is we
have to avoid the use it or lose it
approach to financing healthcare and
reliance on insurance and on government
programs means that every dollar we put
into the system is going to be spent on
health care if you think about in
individuals own life
you save money for rainy days but if it
doesn't rain you may not apply an
umbrella the health care system doesn't
quite work that way right once a lot of
the money we take from people to pay for
insurance premiums Medicare tax Medicare
premiums down the road is in case you
need it but the very fact it's there
means it will be spent on health care
now from an individual's perspective
that may seem irrelevant but from a
society's perspective it's a real
problem because at coming up on very
soon or twenty percent of GDP that
dollars were spending on health care are
things we can't spend on the other good
things in life and you may be aware of
my article I talk about how we don't
even know if we're making the
expenditures that are best for a health
we just know we're making the
expenditures that provide the most
health care those are different things
nobody can answer the question would we
as a society be better off all giving
each ourselves another week vacation or
spending another hundred and fifty
billion on healthcare they're almost
treated differently but they're not
different of course we're at a point in
our health we're over fifty percent of
annual deaths come from conditions or
causes that have more to do with
lifestyle this is of course heart
disease diabetes accident suicide
homicide then they have to do with
health care we've done a great job and
healthcare to get to that point but
being at that point if we're interested
in improving our health we don't know
that these investments are better made
in health care or all the other aspects
of health whether it's recreation or
environment or nutrition or what have
you that are being crowded out by
society's decision to fund health care
in a use it or lose it way so this is
less important for the individual
perhaps and more important for us as a
society so what I'm seeking to do is I'm
seeking to say rather than look for a
magic bullet single way to finance
health care which I think comes out of
that early misconception I talked about
that health care is sort of a lump
emergency need it we know what it is pay
for it that's not true anymore it's much
more complex than that we need to match
the way we finance health care to how we
use it to what it is there are
emergencies that are catastrophic
not all of us will have them it's
completely appropriate for insurance to
finance them insurance is actually most
efficient way to finance them insurance
at the least efficient most costly most
restorative way of financing everything
else
financial one which is people say I
can't afford it I have enough trouble
affording my deductible and they're
right the key to this is that
generational shift I talk about every
year we need to reduce a bit our
reliance on insurance and take some of
the resources we use to pay those
premiums and get them to consumers we
need to gradually over 20 year period
increase the deductible insurance
policies from what they are now to
general catastrophic what that will do
is it will move more in health care
resources to individuals enabling them
to finance their care now the only good
news about spec too and i have trillion
dollars on health care is that all of us
and i mean all of us are spending an
incredible amount of money on care we
may not be aware of it we may think
somebody else is paying for it that's an
illusion you know one of things I looked
at in my article was a higher 23 year
old today and he spends his entire
career with my company and has a spouse
and a couple kids in a few years and
retires at 65 and lives to lady and what
would the amount of money that goes into
the system for that 23 year old and
started am an entry level salary 30
thousand dollars a year which is you
know roughly sixty percent of the
average household income in our country
and had him grow that his income grow at
three percent over the course of his
life gets a salary of little over a
hundred thousand by retires and I made
an assumption which hasn't been true for
50 years which is let's say the growth
of all healthcare is only equal to the
growth of income of course it's been
running one or two points above income
the amazing thing is that 23 year old is
looking at 1.7 million dollars being
spent on his or her behalf to fund his
household so it had medical care over
their lives that's everything that's
their their own share of health
insurance their out-of-pocket their
Medicare premiums from their seniors the
stuff that they actually see but it's
also the stuff they don't see what their
employer paid on their behalf the
Medicare tax that came out and
what's interesting is I realized later
that I understated it because I didn't
include the amount of general tax
revenues that's subsidizing our health
care which is another big bike but let's
let's forget that for a moment I think
if you said to the average 23 year old
you want to participate in this
insurance system or you want a million
dollars over your life to spend on your
own care and if you don't spend it on
your own care you can put it away the
only thing when I ask you to do is I'm
going to insist you by catastrophic
insurance I don't think there's any
question what the average 23 year old
say now you say an average 23 year old
may not be smart enough to make that
decision a long term but let's look at
the impact on everybody in this country
of a health care system that cost the
average employer who pays insurance 12
grand a year per employee 12 grand so if
you are earning the average income in
this country $50,000 your employer is
paying sixty-two thousand dollars let's
forget about Social Security tax and
Medicare tax for a moment for the
privilege of employing you and you're
getting only 50 grand that is an
extraordinary regressive tax the
interesting thing is if you transferred
that 12 grand to the average family they
could buy catastrophic care for the
whole family and have a significant
amount of money left over from savings
the health savings account over here so
you have to be willing to do both you
have to be willing to reduce the
coverage of insurance but transfer those
resources to individuals and if you're
not willing to do both and I'm people
would be afraid that you are of course
that you can't have a consumer driven
system the second concern I think a lot
of people have as consumers aren't wise
enough or smart enough or capable of
driving pricing and quality in our
healthcare system and I think as a lot
of fundamental reforms have to deal with
that seems to be comparing a proposed
new approach with something that doesn't
exist today consumers make all the
decisions on their health care today not
the negative ones but you can't you
can't treat somebody without their
choosing the treatment without their
agreeing to the treatment I'm not
proposing getting rid of doctors I'm not
saying let's think the professionals who
advised you now out of the system and
you design your own treatment and find
someone to do it what I'm saying is
right now we have a system where
doctors advise patients make these
ultimate decisions subject to insurance
company via I am removing the insurance
company from that equation but I don't
think that most consumers would say well
that puts me in a terrible position I
rely on my insurance company to help me
through by life's health care decisions
there's another thing that I think again
comes out of the island nature of health
care very few of us are true active
comparative shoppers and everything we
buy we all benefit from the existence of
Walmart whether we shop there or have
ever in Our Lives compare the price of
toothpaste what happens in a
consumer-driven economy isn't that every
consumer after getting hit by the bus
you know goes to the internet and calls
up emergency surgeons to see who to hire
and at what price what happens is is you
benefit from the fact that the entire
structure of providers is altered to
attract consumers as opposed to serve
insurers and governments that's that
that's the dynamic I'm trying to capture
in a consumer centric approach that
dynamic of providers who answer to us
patient consumers and not to
intermediaries and if you spend time at
a hospital watching a patient be treated
not for a second can you forget that
that patient isn't the customer of that
hospital can't forget it you see it in
the care in almost every element of the
kid and if you've been in the rest of
our economy and bought anything in the
rest of the economy you know that's true
nowhere else and that's a crucial thing
I'm not sure there are there are many I
think some of the objectives that we've
talked about today are things that
people are increasingly aware may matter
in resolving this sort of trap we're in
of every reducing access ever lower
quality and ever higher prices I think
one of them is there's an awareness that
a lack of competition and a lack of
price transparency makes it difficult
for consumers to exercise any of the
Disciplinary force they do in most other
industries there's been a movement in
some states certainly for greater price
transparency unfortunately it's not true
price transparency is list price and of
course hospitals don't charge those
price for anything so it's been fairly
meaningless but it's a step it's an
understanding of the right direction one
of the interesting things that's
occurring and we've seen it occur in
other government programs as well is it
there is the beginnings of something of
a shadow economy in health care for
people who are outside the system for
many of those who either don't have
access to health insurance I can't
afford health insurance there is
increasingly a cash and credit based
economy around health care services
there are parts of this country you can
drive around and see services advertised
on billboards on a cash-only basis you
obviously see some of these clinics that
have opened in Walmart's and CVS is that
get at one of the you know one of the
things you would expect to see in a more
consumer-oriented system which is real
value services for some of the less
complex more easy to replicate treatment
possibilities such as is many in primary
care but I think we have to be we have
to be candid about the walls around the
political process now the reality is
most Americans are happy with their
health insurance and I think some polls
say it's 55 or 60 percent and probably a
percentage of those who have health
insurance and may even be higher and as
long as that's the case we're not going
to expect any politician to propose
fundamental reform they can't there are
enormous interest groups
that exists in that in the provision of
healthcare who would be opposed to
anything that Megaton affects the status
quo negatively from them and obviously
anything we had real discipline on price
would negatively affect the status quo
for this interest groups no politician
is going to buck that for a public that
believes it's got a good deal at 55 or
60 percent approval you can't go at the
fundamental of the system
one of the things that I mentioned in my
article in the reasons I spent a lot of
time on numbers is that I think this is
actually an illusion I think much of
healthcare policy has been about
perpetuating this illusion did somebody
else is magically paying for your care
one things I talk about is because very
common among my fellow liberals is to
say well if we eliminated advertising or
we eliminated the profit motive in order
things I mentioned in my in my article
is if you confiscated the profits of
every single American company forget
about the drug companies and the
hospital companies and the device
manufactory every dollar of profit in
the American economy you'd pay for
something like four or five months of
our health care it two and a half
trillion dollars we're not there yet
we'll be there next year i think the
number this year's likely to be
somewhere between 23 24 but if you want
to have trillion dollars the only people
who can pay for health care is all of us
and we're all paying for an enormous
amounts right you hear people talk all
the time and i got one of the reasons i
have so few friends left is one of the
things i do at dinner parties is talk
about I ask people to mention a health
care bill I have and I break it down
what do you think the costs of that are
but you'll see a five thousand dollar
bill for something that probably had
five or six hundred dollars of marginal
cost and you'll recognize just how
extraordinary the inflation is but
you'll also recognize that what your
friend was worried about was the three
or four hundred dollars they had to pay
against it and you know the difference
in that is costing us all a fortune the
moment at which everybody says you know
it's kind of like having a credit card I
can go out and buy a two-thousand-dollar
plasma television not pay for it at that
moment and tell myself hey this plasma
TV costs me nothing it's the damn credit
card bill it's costing me a fortune
that's what we've done in health care
and unfortunately we have divided the
funding among so many different places
right ourselves our our employer in many
cases various targeted taxes the
government general revenues that people
on sit there and say wow the average
middle class family
is probably looking at twenty thirty
percent of their income somebody
somewhere taking out and paying for
health care that's extraordinarily
regressive and I think if there's
awareness of that or when there's
awareness of that and it may take more
time and more spending and more frayed
safety net and frankly more people
suffering and being hurt for us to get
the realization that there is no free
ride in health care it's costing us all
a fortune and we're all being hurt by
the lack of discipline in the system I
think only then you'll look at the true
fundamental reform being politically
possible for politicians to take the
enormous political risk of saying to
some of the interest groups in health
care I'm sorry but the pie isn't